I'm standing in Victoria station
in London, and as you can see,
there is massive competition
for Wi-Fi connectivity.
Just standing in the same
place, signal strength
is all over the place.
Now, any kind of
connectivity is problematic
in these circumstances.
Delivering a really
good video experience,
that could be a headache.
What can we do about it?
Let's head back to the
studio and find out.
For video and audio
streaming, the web
provides access to over
three billion devices.
Well, as you know, connectivity
can be flaky and changeable,
and bandwidth is often limited.
To cope with real
world connectivity,
we have an open standard for
video streaming and download
called DASH.
With DASH, you deliver video
in segments over a normal HTTP
connection.
Each segment is made available
at a variety of bit rates,
resolutions, and formats.
Depending on the bandwidth
and device capabilities,
the client chooses the
best possible version.
DASH does what it says.
Dynamic, Adaptive,
Streaming, and Download.
And HTTP enables
content delivery
with all the advantages of
HTTP, without the disadvantages
of a traditional
streaming server.
No proprietary protocols
or hardware required.
So, what's the best way
to do DASH on the web?
Let's find out.
Rolling your own adaptive
video solution can be complex.
Shaka Player is a simple-to-use
JavaScript library from Google
that enables you to deliver
the best possible video
and audio to a cheap,
low-res phone on 3G
or a high-spec laptop on
gigabit fiber and everything
in between.
Shaka is plug-in free and
built on web standards,
so it works on
billions of devices.
Let's dive straight in and
build a video player with Shaka.
First up, install polyfills
for legacy browsers.
Then create a Shaka Player for
the video element on the page,
and add an error handler in
case something goes wrong.
Provide the address
of the DASH manifest.
Now, this is the XML file that
describes the alternatives
for each segment of video.
One thing you'll notice
from the manifest
is that DASH enables alternative
formats for the same content
and bit rate, in this
example, WebM, as well as MP4.
Now, that's great for media
delivery to a range of devices.
Next, we create a
bandwidth estimator,
using the Shaka utilities.
And this is crucial
for dynamically
adapting to network conditions.
And finally, load all
that in the Shaka Player.
And that's it,
adaptive streaming
in just a few lines of code.
Now, on the back
end, you'll need
to encode and package your
content ready for streaming.
There are several open
source tools available,
which can be used to convert
content to a valid segmented
file and generate a manifest.
To find out more about DASH
packaging and encoding,
take a look at the links
at the end of the video.
Shaka Player also enables
delivery of protected content,
using the EME APIs to get
licenses and do decryption.
And Shaka supports
multi-lingual content
for audio tracks and subtitles.
The best way to learn more
about Shaka's capabilities
is to download
the Shaka Project.
Run the build tools,
which create example apps
and optimize the
JavaScript code.
On Linux and Mac
systems, run all .sh.
The documentation
has more information
about building on Windows.
I'd recommend you look through
the HTML and JavaScript
for the Shaka test app.
The Shaka GitHub repo
has other resources
to help you get started.
There are several
excellent tutorials
and a test app that exercises
all the capabilities of Shaka
Player.
If you find bugs or
have feature requests,
please file issues on the repo.
Thanks for watching.
See you there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]